en 2022 en France le solde naturel soit
la différence entre les nombres de
naissance et de décès atteint son plus
bas niveau depuis la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale ces données ne sont pas
anecdotiques la France est le deuxième
pays le plus peuplé de l'Union
européenne derrière l'Allemagne la Chine
pays le plus peuplé du monde connaît une
baisse de sa population une première
depuis 60 ans dans ces deux cas certains
parlent de crise démographique est-ce
juste ce phénomène est-il mondial
en France les naissances repartent à la
baisse après une année 2021 post covid
exceptionnel entre 2015 et 2020 les
naissances ont été chaque année de moins
en moins nombreuses l'an dernier
723000 bébés sont nés en France soit
12000 de moins qu'en 2020 cette baisse
de la natalité ne concerne pas que la
France ou la Chine 8 pays de plus de 10
millions d'habitants ont vu leur
population décroître au cours de la
dernière décennie Italie Portugal Grèce
la plupart sont européens mais le Japon
par exemple est également touché ou
encore depuis plus récemment la Corée du
Sud et cette situation va s'amplifier en
Europe la population commencerait à
décliner dès cette décennie à l'horizon
2030 l'Espagne ou l'Allemagne seront
touchés quant à la population mondiale
elle croit au rythme le plus lent depuis
selon les dernières projections des
Nations Unies elle pourrait atteindre un
pic d'environ 10,4 milliards de
personnes au cours des années 2080 et se
maintenir à ce niveau jusqu'en 2100
néanmoins si le nombre d'habitants
d'Europe d'Amérique et d'Asie devrait
commencer à baisser d'ici à 2100 le
nombre d'habitants d'Afrique
continueraient lui à augmenter le nombre
de naissances dépend à la fois du nombre
de femmes en âge de procréer et de leur
fécondité la France avec autour de deux
enfants par femme se situe dans le haut
du tableau au point de vue fécondité et
puis vous avez à l'autre bout du tableau
des pays où la fécondité est descendue
bas un niveau bas alors la Chine mais
vous avez le Japon la Corée du Sud en
Asie de l'Est Corée du Sud où les femmes
ont moins d'un enfant en moyenne chacune
mais vous avez aussi du côté de l'Europe
les pays méditerranéen d'Europe
notamment l'Italie l'Espagne où les
femmes ont autour de
1,2,3 enfants en moyenne chacune en
effet le seuil nécessaire au
renouvellement des générations s'établit
à 2,1 enfants par femme aujourd'hui deux
tiers de la population mondiale vivent
dans un pays où une région où la
fécondité au cours de la vie est
inférieure à ce seuil de 2,1 quant au
nombre de femmes en âge de procréer en
France la population féminine devint à
40 ans âge où les femmes sont les plus
fécondes à diminuer de 8,9% entre 1995
et 2022 enfin dans les pays asiatiques
en particulier les prix de l'immobilier
et le coût de la vie ont fortement
augmenté tout comme celui de l'éducation
d'un enfant les parents font donc moins
d'enfants les femmes ont aussi un niveau
d'études plus élevé elle repousse alors
les grossesses ce qui limitent le nombre
de naissances on a parlé des naissances
mais il y a aussi les décès à prendre
prend en compte d'autant qu'ils sont de
plus en plus élevés en France comment
Europe le vieillissement de la
population s'accélère depuis le milieu
des années 2010 en 2021 les personnes de
65 ans ou plus représentent 21% de la
population de l'Union européenne contre
18% en 2011 au niveau mondial les
personnes âgées constituent le groupe
d'âge qui enregistre la croissance la
plus rapide en 2018 pour la première
fois le nombre de personnes âgées dans
le monde a dépassé celui des enfants de
moins de 5 ans et d'ici à 2050 il
dépassera celui des adolescents et des
jeunes alors concernant les les décès en
fait il faut se rappeler que la bonne
nouvelle de ces dernières décennies
c'est non seulement la hausse de
l'espérance de vie en moyenne toutes ces
dernières décennies c'est une hausse de
l'espérance de vie et surtout une hausse
de l'espérance de vie des personnes
âgées donc le résultat c'est qu'il y a
de plus en plus de personnes âgées mais
que bien entendu toute personne âgées et
soumis aux risques de mortalité donc
quand les personnes âgées sont plus
nombreuses et bien ça engendre à terme
inévitablement un nombre de décès plus
important je crois que le cas du Japon
est très intéressant à cet égard puisque
on voit bien que le nombre de décès
augmente au Japon c'est la plus longue
espérance de vie de tous les pays du
monde les projections de l'Insee
publiées il y a un peu plus d'un an
annonce dans leur scénario moyen que
cette augmentation des décès devrait
conduire à une annulation du solde
naturel
dans une quinzaine d'années et du coup
dans quelques décennies il faut
s'attendre à impossible sol naturel
négatif donc plus de décès que de
naissance ça correspondra donc à la
période
s'éteindront les générations nombreuses
de baby-boom les démographes et
économistes redoutent l'impact du déclin
à venir et du vieillissement de la
population sur l'économie mondiale
pourquoi qu'elle pourrait en être les
conséquences la première conséquence
économique des phénomènes notamment de
dépeuplements ou de dépopulation c'est
tout simplement la baisse de population
active alors toute chose égale par
ailleurs moins vous avez d'actifs moins
vous pouvez créer de richesse et puis
bien sûr il y a aussi tous les coûts du
vieillissement qu'il faut qu'il faut
assumer et les dépenses liées au coût du
vieillissement
sont des dépenses qui peuvent être par
consacrées à l'investissement du futur
il faut il ne faut pas oublier les
conséquences géopolitiques des
évolutions démographiques ce que
j'appelle la loi du nombre et la loi du
nombre elle a des effets géopolitiques
selon les projections de l'ONU le nombre
d'habitants de la planète devrait
croître de 2 milliards d'ici 2050
passant de 7,7 à 9,7 milliards pour
plafonner à 10,4 milliards à la fin du
siècle c'était des évolutions qui
étaient prévisibles en ce qui concerne
la France la baisse de la fécondité et
donc le fait qu'aujourd'hui l'écart
entre les naissances et les décès soit
devenu très faible et tout simplement la
conséquence des décisions politiques qui
ont été prises au cours des années 2010
donc il y a pas de de crise
démographique si vous voulez
à court moyen terme et surtout si on met
en regard les grands défis de l'humanité
que ce soit le réchauffement climatique
l'épuisement des ressources la
dégradation de la biodiversité et
finalement
on sera autour de 10 milliards à la fin
du siècle un peu en dessous un peu au
dessus guère moins pour autant cette
accroissement démographique
reviendra pour moi de chez de neuf pays
seulement à l'inverse les populations de
61 pays ou région devraient diminuer
dans le monde d'ici à 2050 et selon
certains économistes et démographes ce
chiffre pourrait même être bien
supérieur